[Music]
all right a little pop quiz
how long do you guys think
it takes
with the technology that we have through
nasa
or any spacecraft to reach mars from
earth two years right yeah i was going
to say two and a half my honest answer
where did you guys get those numbers i
just guessed oh what do you guys think i
think we probably have the technology
right now but they're not giving it to
us because i just recently saw this meme
where i get my science from
[Laughter]
the inventor of a stealth bomber right
he he quote he was quoting um and i
don't know if this is [ __ ] real but
he was in front of a stealth bomber and
it said that
the technology that we have you can't
even
like basically
whatever you imagine we probably have it
that was anything
yeah they're like it's they're just
light years beyond what the military has
and whatever it's just it's
incomprehensible to the average person
so also you know the whole ufo sightings
and all that stuff they're saying that's
just just government crafts that they're
testing whoa yeah they do say it's like
the military is like 25 years ahead of
normal commercial technology that's
pretty cool so according to nasa
uh it takes 500 days so yeah you're
right oh it's like a little bit over
almost two years a real year under two
years but according to a new group of
canadian engineers who have developed
a new laser system
it could cut time down to 45 days 45
days if you don't believe it what does
that mean like they just shine a light
please
okay so like what they do is they shrink
you guys to us to a molecule of course
and then they shoot you in the laser and
they pee so what you're explaining is
the technology that willy wonka used to
shrink mike tv no rick moranis no it's
more like the one that well willy wonka
came out before you know roald dahl
wrote that that book way before honey i
trust kids i'm not saying maybe their
technologies are based on each other oh
yeah that's true what do you how do you
think the laser could make that faster
[ __ ] dude you're asking the wrong side
from a muay thai perspective
is it from the elbows
use the angle don't stick your thumb out
and just swipe
oh [ __ ] he's got the laser technology in
45 days
[Laughter]
i just pictured a canadian nerd holding
a [ __ ] laser pointer and going see 45
days
[Laughter]
45 days
thank you
so we just have to sit here for 45 more
days
so what i understand is this right like
you have earth you have the sun if the
earth is going around the sun like this
then you have mars going around the sun
but everything is going this way so it
has to be very accurately timed because
you can run into asteroids run into
moves run into everything
so the lasers probably help with i think
there's only one moon right
or there's other movies you said moods
we're really going from earth to mars
the other planets so i don't know
smaller moons wait there is no other
planet
is there what do you mean i'm not i'm
thinking about it no mercury goes
mercury venus no no i mean like there's
nothing between earth yeah you're right
yeah but it's going like this right
earth is spinning at a certain rate
there is no other place there's no other
planets like what other planets mars is
spinning at a certain rate and they got
so you gotta i'm interested i want to
make the first pluto now all yeah you
got to catch them at the right time and
you have space debris and you have all
that [ __ ] okay space trash so you
can easily smash your [ __ ] space shut
onto something if it's too fast so you
want to be fast enough to where you'll
be like oh asteroid and then you
couldn't do move like a game you know
like the asteroid game
it is very close to that so wouldn't i
there will be a time with like where the
sun is in between the earth and mars you
know so you can't go through that also
got to plan it out
wow
look at all the black holes out there
bro you gotta worry about that too it's
underrated why don't people just [ __ ]
use a black hole
i heard that you could go through one
black hole and go through the other one
you see that movie event horizon i was
molested back
that movie scared the [ __ ] out of me
wait what event horizon yeah they
because this is what they do they send a
space team out to [ __ ] saturn okay
they get lost and then they go we need
to go find them how we gonna find them
we're gonna go through a black hole the
black hole teleports us it cuts the time
in half right but what they don't
realize is going through the black hole
sends them straight to [ __ ] hell
that's event horizon that's eventually
that's the movie that's so they mix
christianity with space
wow
and so my dumb ass being like five years
old being like i'm gonna watch this
movie and i'm like oh [ __ ] at five
i was allowed to watch anything and
everything as long as it didn't have sex
so my parents were like oh you're gonna
watch you know rambo live yeah didn't
care terminator two i'm like four i'm
like yeah they're like dope
love the part where he shows up naked
i'm like they're like you can watch
event horizon just don't watch the porno
based office no no i'm actually writing
it down because i want to watch that now
you made it you sold it it's just a 90s
film uh i thought there's a lot of new
jack swing
i think lawrence fishburne is here
imagine that oh we're in hell
[Laughter]
you're pretty good at dancing man
in hell this never got out of style
[Laughter]
is everyone wearing overalls and
pinstripes not but with one with one
overall though only one overall shroud
rising baby yeah
it's the best movie ever
because
i'm all like oh it's all the boys
everyone's got their clothes on
backwards
it would be funny to do an updated
version oh because the reason why is
every single person who was on the ship
had their own version of hell they
hallucinated differently so it was like
the stuff that specifically would scare
them that's yours
yours would be the new jackson
we would all be standing there like we'd
all have like demons and people getting
possessed loved ones getting killed and
then him it would just be like a bunch
of 90s dancers like
but ryan can't handle it
and you guys are like what do you see
what do you see and all of us are like i
can't even say it what the [ __ ]
i can't even say it ryan dies firstly i
can't take it
no not kid and play
i can't do it anymore i can't do it dude
so uh to answer finally you guys
question
how this [ __ ] laser does it
so it it's literally like a
giant laser they build how big on the
surface i think it's like 37 feet
like out
and then it's got um it'll just shoot a
laser at a spacecraft like at the
hydrogen fuel to heat it wow
and it'll just blast that like muay thai
it'll just
yeah
it's like an enema for the rocket ship
animals work too many it's a hot muay
thai enema for a space shuttle it's a
bidet yeah it's a hot bidet laser just
keeps blasting boom
it'll just keep the [ __ ] out of it
because because this isn't like for
space travel the hardest thing is
getting out of the uh atmosphere
atmosphere yeah because once you're gone
they just it just logs you're just going
at whatever speed you you grabbing yeah
rejection yeah the angle have you seen
that one it's like a satellite but um
they they made it like into a sail and
once it's launched out they just use the
momentum of it to just get to mars and
ship yeah i think the the panel also
measures solar flares yeah
and it like self propels
yeah so that would be like that's 45
days for a spacecraft carrying people as
far as satellites dude sometimes that's
like way less one time it took me like
40 days to get back from india oh [ __ ]
40 days were you on noah's ark or what
the delhi airport got closed for like
two weeks because it was just [ __ ]
foggy from fog yeah it was just super
foggy like how bad was the fog like they
couldn't see i mean i'm not a pilot but
it was that bad but i'm gonna trust them
to be like oh we should take off and be
like all right yeah
you were you stuck at the airport for
that long so they sent us back to uh
this hotel which was basically a
[ __ ]
which was hilarious there was like
cockroaches everywhere and like but it
was free
yo yeah it was free it was free but
people were pissed at the airport yeah i
would be too you know
just riots two weeks
i was there for the airport for three
days wow it took three days to get our
flight like ready to go
oh [ __ ] but that's long it wasn't modern
era would you go to would you go to mars
if it was 45 days
no one no one here is interested at all
i like it here man let other people go
what if you get your black belt way
faster
i'll stay here bro he's one belt away
dude you're a different weight class
think about it think about it i'll say
if it make my penis bigger then i'm in
dude
that's the only stipulation have you
seen the like rover photos right to me
it's like why go there when there's las
vegas that's about to say it looks like
vegas yeah it's the same [ __ ] but i'm
not trying to mars bro
but like other bless you other than
going to another planet which obviously
is pretty dope yeah i might i want to
see i'd love to go to the moon
that'd be nice yeah it would be cool to
see earth from that perspective
and i think that would be life-changing
yeah that's true that's true i would
like to go to another earth-like planet
because you know how they say they found
other earth like and then i want to see
if like you know the oceans look the
same and [ __ ] yeah that'd be pretty
exciting because when you look at
pictures of mars and stuff the whole
planet just looks like this if you've
seen one side of mars it's all the same
but they'd say they're saying there's
like ice
ice underneath the surface and there's
what possible we got ice here bro it
just snowed over here
they sent worms up to space to see how
it would change them and apparently they
mutated and they grew two heads and then
when they brought them back to earth
they they removed one head and then like
they uh it still grew back which
ultimately then proved that they were
genetically
altered
for good from being in space
they became two-headed worms yeah a
little bit they don't i don't know what
happens to us will be going to space
marshall actually thinking it's gonna do
it
dude you ever need to cut wait for a
fight just go to space for like five
days and then come back and then when
you come back you're just frail and you
can't do anything you can't walk yeah
you have to relearn everything i have a
feeling we're never going to sell you on
going to mars i think you're a mars
hater i hate no look i'll say this i'll
say this for for the advancement of
human civilization that's fire it's cool
because i first i was like who the [ __ ]
wants to go to mars but when i hear
other people that are smarter than me
talk about this [ __ ]
i'm like that's tight that's really cool
but that's that's way beyond what i'm
going to do if i go to mars i'm just
dead weight bro i got to stay here but
what if you want to you can train for 45
days you can train in the hyperbolic
time chamber at like a hundred times
gravity like goku did would that make me
cooler though will that make me look
like goku
will i get will i get myself
if i had to guess you'd probably have a
brain aneurysm before you made it there
but
you could maybe be very but you'll be
the deadest guy with the blackest belt
oh man dude he turned the ship around i
knew i could get you
[Music]
you